كتاب في ملاعب خصام في المجالس حماس امام
الشاشات تلك هي الصوره في السعوديه منذ
عقود وتلك هي منذ زمن طويل
في السعوديين مع كره القدم لكن شيئا مات
يتغير الشغف القديم لم يموت لكن شغفا
جديدا ياخذ مكانه في قلوب السعوديه الفنون
والتربيه
[موسيقى]
انديه كره القدم مثل الهلال النصر في
الرياض والاتحاد والاهلي في جده تتمتع
بالملايين المشجعين
كره القدم في الواقع
وجميع
حديث
ا من عشاق الفنون والترفيق في البلاد
يتفوقون بكثير على عشاق الكره القدم
[موسيقى]
ارقام هيئه الترفيه بينت ان الحفلات
الغنائيه والموسيقيه في المسارح والساحات
والعروض الحيه في المطاعم والمقاهي
والمسابقات المتنوعه استقطبت 120 مليون
زائر في غضون اربع سنوات فقط وبمتوسط 30
مليون زائر في السنه وهو رقم كبير لا تصل
له بطولات كره القدم المختلفه
[موسيقى]
هناك من راى في هذه الارقام تراجعا لشعبيه
كره القدم لكن هناك من قرا الارقام من
زاويتها الاخرى التحولات المذهله التي
تشهدها السعوديه جعلت الفنون مكانا اكبر
في نفط المجتمع وفي قلوب الناس لصباح
العربيه محمد خالد الرياض